[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
journée chargée pour le gouvernement
avec un conseil des ministres ce matin
sous le signe du coville objectif
rétablir les protocoles sanitaires à
quelques jours de la rentrée scolaire
qui inquiète ont vu du requin de
l'épidémie jean michel blanquer a
annoncé le port du masque obligatoire
les adultes et les enfants à partir de
11 ans dans les établissements scolaires
troisième nuit de violences à kenosha
aux états unis deux personnes ont été
tuées par balles lors de manifestations
suite à une nouvelle affaire de
violences policières de notre impatience
ce soir des renforts contre je cite les
pillages et l'anarchie j'attends blake
un afro américain de 29 ans a été
grièvement blessé par un policier blanc
l'homme est paralysée selon l'avocat de
la famille
[Musique]
l'allemagne exhorté la grèce et la
turquie ne pas jouer avec le feu une
médiation qui ne change rien pour ankara
aucune concession ne sera faite prévient
le président turc
athènes se dit prêt à discuter tout en
défendant sa souveraineté berlin mettant
en garde contre un risque de
confrontation militaire et appelle au
dialogue direct
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur arte
france si vous nous rejoignez le
coronavirus plus que jamais au centre
des discussions pour cette rentrée
politique
la france enregistré 3304 nouvelles
contaminations ces dernières 24 heures
et contrant cinq nouveaux foyers
épidémiques dans ce contexte la belgique
place paris en zone rouge imposant test
de dépistage et période d'isolement
l'exécutif s'est donc concentré
aujourd'hui sur les protocoles
sanitaires port du masque obligatoire
pour les lycéens et collégiens chômage
partiel maintenu jusqu'au 1er novembre à
quelques jours de la rentrée
l'exécutif multiplient les prises de
paroles pour rassurer les français
inquiets du rebond de l'épidémie
françois tessier beach priorité santé
déclare emmanuel macron à l'issue du
conseil de défense spéciales cos vite de
ce mardi une annonce qui se traduit par
de nouvelles mesures fermeture des bars
et restaurants du département des
bouches du rhône dès 23h et masque
obligatoire dans toute la ville de
marseille des restrictions qui pourrait
s'appliquer à paris un scénario qu
envisage désormais le porte parole du
gouvernement
rien est exclue par principe il ya un
travail qui engagez-vous constater aussi
que la circulation du virus est
importante dans la capitale et dans un
certain nombre de départements de la
petite couronne
d'ailleurs sur la région ile de france
il ya aussi une préoccupation est
évidemment le pré les préfets et les
élus sont en lien constant pour préparer
d'éventuelles nouvelles mesures
autre annonce attendue celle du ministre
de l'éducation nationale
à moins d'une semaine d'une inquiétante
rentrée pour plus de 12 millions
d'élèves
jean marie blanque et à préciser les
nouvelles règles à respecter dans les
établissements scolaires il est exact
qu'en juillet et août nous avions
envisagé quelques éventuels exception je
pense aux professeurs de maternelle je
pense à certaines situations
pédagogiques à une certaine distance
nous avons préféré ne pas maintenir ces
exceptions de façon à ce que la règle
soit totalement claire totalement simple
et puis qu'il n'y ait pas de casuistique
et donc j'ai vu que c'était aussi le
point de vue de une bonne partie des
organisations syndicales
une bonne partie des acteurs donc
aujourd'hui tout le monde doit retire
cette idée très simple les adultes
portent le masque
et les enfants les élèves aussi
s'agissant des élèves à partir de la
classe de 6e c'est le principe socle de
ce protocole sanitaire le port du masque
sera également rendue obligatoire dans
les entreprises à partir de mardi
prochain une mesure qualifiée d' un peu
brutale par le patron du medef geoffroy
roux de bézieux lors de l'ouverture de
l'université d'été de l'organisation
patronale
il appelle le gouvernement à l'essai de
la souplesse aux entreprises pour mettre
en place cette mesure également présents
à cette journée inaugurale
jean castex a levé le voile sur une
partie des dispositions du plan de
relance qui sera présentée le 3
septembre
parmi elles le maintien du chômage
partiel au moins jusqu'au 1er novembre
dans les entreprises qui sont encore
confrontés aujourd'hui à une réduction
d'activité durable me conduit également
à vous annoncer que l'activité partielle
demeurera ouverte dans ces conditions
actuelles au moins jusqu'au 1er novembre
au moins jusqu'au 1er novembre et au
delà
pendant deux ans pour toutes les
entreprises couvertes par un accord sur
l'activité partielle longue durée demain
matin le locataire de matignon tiendra
une conférence de presse aux côtés des
ministres de la santé olivier ferrand et
de l'éducation nationale jean marie
blanque r il devrait faire le point sur
l'épidémie
département par département défendent
les nouvelles mesures et appelé à
davantage de vigilance et notez
également que le premier ministre a
annoncé que les conditions actuelles
d'indemnisation du chômage partiel
serait maintenue au moins jusqu'au 1er
novembre
alors qu'elle devait être revu à la
baisse au 1er octobre
jean castex a rappelé que les
entreprises avaient la possibilité de
recourir aux nouveaux dispositifs
d'activité partielle de longue durée en
vigueur depuis fin juillet et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct avec
nicolas glières professeur et membre du
collectif les stylos rouges
bonsoir
nicolas glières merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france avant votre
premier première réaction cette
conférence de presse de jean michel
blanquer le protocole sanitaire vous
semble satisfaisant vous êtes rassuré
que ce soir bonsoir
toujours par agent michel blanc caire
par le bouc ou ne fait pas grand chose
d'autre que de la com le protocole date
du 7 juillet ne l'a quasiment pas
amender ce protocole ne prend pas
vraiment en compte les personnes
fragiles 200 mille enseignants sont
considérés comme fragile par rapport au
co lead
que vont ils faire alors pour l'instant
une vague solution c'est soi et de se
mettre en arrêt maladie soit ils peuvent
soit ils font cours avec un masque
chirurgical
donc concrètement on n'envisage pas du
tout de faire cours à distance dans les
faits c'est complètement absurde
donc non nous ne sommes pas rassurés du
tout le quotid circulent plus à ce qu'on
nous dit des mesures plus drastiques
sont prises partout
je rappelle qu'on ne peut pas faire de
sport en salle on peut parfois peut pas
aller à dans un club ou autre on peut
pas aller dans un stade mais en revanche
à l'école pas de problème c'est super
d'être à 35 dans 35 mètres carrés à
l'école tout se passe bien on peut
circuler les uns les autres dans un
couloir
c'est pas dangereux voilà donc à l'école
c'est pas dangereux dans la rue c'est
dangereux
je ne comprends pas la cohérence du
gouvernement alors on peut effectivement
quand même aller dans des dans des
salles de sport homme masqué mais
effectivement quand on fait du sport on
a le droit d'enlever les masques pour
être précis nicolas de lierre qu'est-ce
que vous aurez auriez souhaité vous
dites des mesures drastiques mais
qu'elle est effectivement la solution
pour que tous les enfants puissent se
retourner aujourd'hui à l'école alors
une solution possible que nous
préconisions je fais des stylos rouges
ces deux reproches qui avait en mai
c'est à dire de prendre les élèves en
demi groupe est de s'occuper des autres
pendant qu'ils ne sont pas là par
exemple en partie ont cours à distance
ça c'était faisable on est prêt à le
faire ce n'est pas le scénario que le
ministère a voulu suivre
il faut savoir que monsieur blanquart
n'écoute jamais les enseignants n'écoute
pas les organes aux astros les
organisations syndicales non plus en ce
qui concerne nos salaires c'est la même
chose
le plomb qui nous annoncent ils parlent
de 400 millions d'euros c'était 500 à la
base nous demandons 10 milliards il
n'augmentera probablement que quelques
enseignants en début de carrière
ce n'est pas du tout ce qui est demandé
manque de salaire on est mal payé on est
mal considéré on est mal traité nous
nous demandions 43 % d'augmentation pour
tous parce qu'on perd du salaire depuis
1983 c'est une réalité acceptée par le
ministère et on nous propose dans les
faits à peu près 150 à 200 millions
d'augmentation
monsieur blanc caire n'écoute pas les
enseignants
quel que soit le point si vous voulez
que ce soit sur nos salaires sur les
moyens pour faire court on continue à
payer notre matériel nos ordinateurs nos
stylos rouges et autres et puis sur le
respect qui nous est dû ils ont continué
à subir du harcèlement continue à subir
des menaces des intimidations quand on
témoigne dont les médias quand on
témoigne quand on manifeste tout
simplement de ce qui se passe à l'école
donc ça ne peut plus durer
nous nous sommes très remontés nous nous
comptons bien reprendre le 1er septembre
mais nous comptons aussi nous faire
entendre le temps qu'il faudra pour que
monsieur blanc caire comprennent enfants
qu'il doit nous augmente et que nous
méritons d'être bien payé
il est resté à l'époque de nicolas
sarkozy elle a dix ans de retard
nous ne voulons pas travailler plus pour
gagner plus
or sup les heures sup on n'en veut pas
surtout qu'elles sont mal payés nous
voulons être bien payé et bien traités
pour le métier nécessaire que nous
faisons pourquoi vous êtes contre l'idée
des heures sup si elle était mieux payé
est ce que vous seriez ouverts à cette
possibilité
parce que notre travail a été calculé en
1950 on a plus de 50% de notre travail
en télétravail je vais je vais vite je
peux être de rentrer dans le technique
et concrètement n'a jamais bénéficié des
baisses de temps de travail tout le
monde pense que nous sommes des
glandeurs fini libre aux gens de le
penser nous travaillons largement assez
monsieur darcos avait calculé à 43
heures hne dans les donateurs de travail
42 ans et demi je crois précisément donc
les heures sup ne sont pas une solution
il faut payer les gens pour le travail
qu'ils font à temps complet nous sommes
à temps complet or ce n'est pas le cas
on nous propose des heures sup qui sont
payé pareil en début de carrière en fin
de parcours hier aux fins de carrière il
n'y a aucune évolution déjà sept ans
pardonnez moi mais c'est important ce
que vous nous dites parce qu'autant
mettre les pieds dans le plat ce
malentendu voilà les gens pensent qu'on
est des glandeurs fini je ne sais pas
voilà qui vous vous pensez
mais c'est vrai que peut-être qu'un
salarié lambda vous dire eh ben non on a
cinq semaines de vacances vous en avez
voilà on je ne sais pas d'ailleurs
combien les enfants non énormément en
tout cas qu'est ce que vous répondez
justement à ces gens qui se disent vas
nous on a cinq semaines de vacances
voilà dans le droit commun en tout cas
alors déjà beaucoup de métier on 9/10
11/12 pas tous mais beaucoup depuis les
rtt
la deuxième chose c'est que nous pendant
nos vacances nous travaillons et je peux
vraiment vous assurer qu'on travaille
beaucoup pendant nos vacances pendant
les jours fériés pendant les vacances
quand on prépare des cours qu'on corrige
les copies qu'on élabore des cours en
français en histoire pour vous donner
une idée on lit des bouquins pour
nourrir notre cour c'est pas du loisir
ça fait partie de notre travail les gens
ne se rendent pas compte
les gens n'imaginent pas en fait ce que
ça se travaille je ne veux pas dire que
c'est le bagne mais simplement ça
nécessite du temps c'est du temps aussi
à la maison donc ses vacances ne sont
pas des vacances comme d'autres salariés
peuvent avoir on rentre du boulot on n'y
pense plus ce n'est pas notre cas il y a
des avantages et des défauts à chaque
métier ça serait pas mal que notre
métier ne viennent pas qu'un immense
défaut c'est ça que je veux dire voilà
aujourd'hui très rapidement qu'on vous
dit on veut se faire entendre vous allez
reprendre les cours le 1er septembre
mais dans quel état d'esprit et avec
peut-être l'arrière pensée d'une journée
de mobilisation proche les modalités
restent à voir on en discute entre nous
l'idée n'est pas du tout de nous on veut
pas nuire aux parents on veut pas nuire
à la société on veut être entendu s'il
faut en passer par là où il fera aussi
peu importe mais nous on veut être
entendu du ministre on veut le
rencontrer on veut le revoir
il n'a jamais entendu ce qu'on voulait
lui dire on a été reçu deux fois
ministère ça n'a strictement servi à
rien je l'avais déjà dit à l'époque mais
on nous a servi du coca dans des verres
à pied non vas pas au ministère pour ça
on va pas discuter avec des gens dans
une ambiance bourgeoise on veut de
l'efficacité ce qu'on veut c'est être
entendu qu on nous augmente qu'on nous
respecte qu'on nous traite bien que le
protocole sanitaire soit cohérent par
rapport au reste du gouvernement et de
la société
quel que soit le sens toi le virus est
dangereux et est en regain soit il n'est
pas dangereux il n'est pas un regard
mais on peut pas être dans les deux
discours sous prétexte de faire marcher
l'économie ou autres voilà il faut
trouver quelque chose de cohérent notre
lignano je vous le répète c'est en 2000
roues
du travail en présentiel du travail à
distance et puis que tous les
enseignants mais aussi tous les
personnels d'éducation soient clairement
et massivement aux enfants augmente et
qu'on le réclame à cor et à cri depuis
un an et demi merci beaucoup nicolas
bière je rappelle donc que vous êtes
membre du collectif les stylos rouges
merci à vous donald trump annonce des
renforts contre les pillages et
l'anarchie selon lui après une nouvelle
nuit de violence aux états unis suite à
la sphère jacob blakes jeunes
afro-américains grièvement blessé par un
policier le mouvement black light moteur
repart de plus belle à kenosha ville où
a eu lieu l'incident deux personnes sont
mortes lors de ces rassemblements
retour sur les événements avec valentin
carpentier ces images font le tour du
monde depuis maintenant trois jours
jacob black 29 ans se fait tirer dessus
à sept reprises par un policier lors
d'un contrôle à kenosha dans le
wisconsin
il n'en fallait pas plus aux activistes
de blacklight matters pour appeler à une
nouvelle mobilisation alors que
l'assassinât de georges floyd est encore
dans les mémoires
le mouvement demande que justice soit
faite
le combat est donc relancé et certains
américains se disent fatigués de voir
encore l'histoire se répéter j'ai été
vraiment choqués parce que je ne pensais
pas que quelque chose comme ça
arriverait aujourd'hui dans ce climat
après toutes ces manifestations à
travers le monde
je ne pensais pas qu'il pourrait faire
ça sans vergogne et sans faire attention
quand même prendre en compte tout le
travail que nous avons fait sur ce qui
se passe vous devez utiliser cette
colère cette frustration ce sentiment de
lassitude que vous avez pour faire plier
les dirigeants de ce pays là maintenant
utiliser vos voix pour être sûr qu'il
sache ce qu'on veut
depuis trois jours la ville de kenosha
est le théâtre de violences entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
des affrontements qui ont même entraîné
la mort de deux personnes tuées par
balles la nuit dernière face à cette
situation explosive
la famille de jacob blake appel au calme
tout en demandant justice
il faudra un miracle il faudra un
miracle pour que jacob black junior
marche à nouveau
il est en ce moment même au bloc
opératoire
il continue de se battre pour rester en
vie j'ai constaté énormément de dégâts
en venant ici à travers la ville cela
n'est pas à l'image de mon fils ni de ma
famille
[Musique]
tchèque a dit jacobs savez ce qu'il se
passait la violence et la destruction de
charles manson
ils ont tiré sur mon fils cette fois
sauvé
comme s'ils n'avaient pas d'importance
mais monfils compte inox est un être
humain et il compte une enquête pour
déterminer les circonstances du drame a
été ouverte et les deux policiers
impliqués ont été suspendus de leurs
fonctions
des voix se font déjà entendre dans tout
le pays dont celle du candidat démocrate
à la présidentielle joe biden pour
exiger une enquête transparente
de son côté donald trump a demandé au
gouverneur du wisconsin de faire appel à
la garde nationale pour mettre fin aux
manifestations
trois mois après la mort de georges
floyd
les etats unis doivent de nouveau faire
face à leurs vieux démons le combat de
blagues l'animateur semble lui loin
d'être gagné et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec laurent
cesarini professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université d'arras
bonsoir ans et harry merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france que nous
dit cette nouvelle affaire aux états
unis aucune leçon tirée de la sphère
floyd pour l'instant non et c'était
intéressant d'ailleurs parce que cette
police de qu'est le chat depuis 2007
fait 2010 est excusez moi il ya eu un
vote unanime de la municipalité pour la
lui fournir des caméras de surveillance
obligatoire pour les pour les policiers
et il n'en avait pas pour une raison
simple c'est que pour des raisons
budgétaires ça coûtait trop cher et donc
c'est seulement en 2022 semble-t-il
qu'ils les auront mais le
honneur du wisconsin a appelé
aujourd'hui une session spéciale delà du
parlement de l'état pour le 31 août pour
voter une série de mesures de réforme de
la police d'autant que je suis posé ses
caméras et cetera
ça vient tard effectivement mais ce qui
est certain effectivement c'est georges
flotte c'était il ya environ deux mois
il n'ya pas lui il ya eu un fort
mouvement d'opinion mais il n'y a pas
encore eu encore de deux changements en
pratique significatif et le mouvement
effectivement la volonté politique nenê
n'est pas là on entend effectivement
donald trump parler de pillage
d'anarchie il ne va pas en profondeur
dans les problèmes il ne cherche pas
effectivement la cause et se contente si
j'ose dire de condamner pas de prise de
conscience politique tout simplement de
résumer ainsi les deux choses du côté
républicain
c'est très net puisque du côté
tout le programme consiste en fait à le
nous a présenté les blancs comme une
minorité opprimée elle même
donc évidemment il ya absolument pas
qu'il ne vend pas question du côté de
trump d'avoir une autre réponse que que
la répression
du côté aux démocrates que vous l'avez
dit by dane notamment d'une enquête
c'est bien le minimum ma foi mais en
face à contraste évidemment avec avec ce
que fait trump est quand même le comble
quand le
l'honneur du christ comme s'il est un
démocrate donc effectivement on peut
dire de deux mois c'est à la fois long
et court
on aurait pu penser que l'assassinât de
tuer moi du terme mais oui euh comment
dire de georges de flore et accélère les
choses en fait pas tellement il est
possible maintenant que cette deuxième
affaire
les accélère vraiment du moins c'est ce
que je peux espérer
en tout cas il ya une prise de
conscience à défaut de donald trump de
son épouse mélanie et rome qui est un
petit peu surpris là où son mari
effectivement parle des métiers la
première dame elle a appelé à apprendre
de notre passé la difficile réalité
c'est que nous ne sommes pas fiers de
pan de notre histoire a déclaré mel
anatome compense l'historien que vous
êtes et ce sera ma dernière question de
ce que dit mélanie est justement de
l'histoire sa tranche vraiment avec le
discours de son mari qui condamne l
appel a justement avec le discours du
mari qui dit il n'y a rien à changer et
sert à eux
j'avoue classé e effectivement et
melania trump a toujours un aspect un
peu plus comment dire je vais demander
pardonnez-moi laurence hézard y fait
qu'est-ce que c'est la bonne solution on
prend le problème dans le bon sens de
justement interrogé l'histoire et voilà
de la remettre en cause
sasa certaine ça peut pas faire de
maliens lourd bilan aux états unis je
crois que du côté du côté des démocrates
s'est fait très très nettement
quant au résultat pratique c'est
peut-être une autre affaire du côté
républicain
s'il s'engage de ce côté là là
effectivement ça sera une nouveauté
parce qu'il faut bien dire les choses
comme elles sont depuis les années 1960
le parti républicain comme programme
implicite à un racisme larvé il faut
bien le dire merci beaucoup laurent
cesari je rappelle vous êtes professeur
d'histoire contemporaine à l'université
d'arras d'avoir été avec nous
l'iran autorise finalement l' agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique a
visité deux sites nucléaires depuis
plusieurs mois les yeux a demandé cet
accès afin de clarifier ses des
activités nucléaires non déclarées il y
avait eu lieu au début des années 2000
une annonce dans un contexte de tensions
avec les états unis et ce nouvel échec
pour le président américain il tente
d'imposer des sanctions internationales
contre l'iran mais hier le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu à rejeter sa demande
d'un tram ne s'avoue pas vaincu et
invoque le fait que l'iran ait violé ses
engagements les détails et grâce d'aia
donald trump fait le forcing
alors que le président américain a
retiré les états unis en 2010 8 de
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
concret en 2015 estimant trop peu
contraignant la semaine dernière
washington a envoyé une notification à
l'onu objectif le retour des sanctions
internationales contre l'iran
notre message est très très simple les
états unis ne permettrons jamais aux
plus grands états qui soutient le
terrorisme d'acheter et de vendre
librement des avions des chars des
missiles et d'autres types d'armes
conventionnelles
ces sanctions des nations unies
maintiendront l'embargo sur les armes
donald trump s'appuie sur une résolution
particulière le snap bac qui permet à un
état participant à l'accord de demander
un rétablissement des sanctions s'il
juge que cet accord a été violée
pour les états unis l'accord n'est plus
valable l'iran ayant violé sa promesse
de ne pas développer d'armes nucléaires
nous avons rappelé aux membres notre
droit en vertu de la résolution 2231 de
déclencher un retour en arrière et notre
ferme intention de le faire en l'absence
de courage et de clarté morale de la
part du conseil
la demande américaine a été rejetée
mardi par la présidence du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies pour 13 des
15 membres les états unis n'ont plus de
base légale pour déclencher une
procédure de snap bac ayant perdu leur
statut d'état participant à l'accord du
gouvernement iranien n'était donc pas
inquiet c'est une résolution très
inégale et en fait elle utilise les
mécanismes du conseil de sécurité pour
détruire le conseil de sécurité je suis
persuadé que cette résolution sera
également rejeté le mécanisme de retour
en arrière
parfaitement clair et juridiquement
parlant l'amérique n'a aucun droit de
l'utiliser alors que l'embargo sur les
armes à destination de l'iran expire au
mois d'octobre locataire de la maison
blanche semble déterminé à créer une
crise au sein du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu son objectif semble clair tenter
de tuer l'accord sur le nucléaire avant
les élections ou le rendre très
difficile à remettre en place même en
cas d'alternance à la maison blanche
berlin prônent le dialogue entre la
turquie et la grèce pour éviter une
catastrophe le différend maritime qui
oppose les deux pays depuis des
décennies s'est envenimée ces dernières
semaines en cause la recherche
d'hydrocarbures en méditerranée
orientale le ministre allemand des
affaires étrangères a rencontré hier ses
homologues turc et grec
chacune des deux parties à accepter le
principe du dialogue tout en campant sur
ses positions
la turquie en méditerranée en mer egée
en mer noire obtiendra ce qui lui
revient de la même manière que nous
n'avons pas les yeux sur le territoire
la souveraineté les intérêts d'autres
nous le ferons absolument aucune
concession sur ce qui nous appartient
nous invitons nos homologues à se
ressaisir et à se garder de toute erreur
qui ouvrirait la voie à leur ruine
ce dont nous avons besoin immédiatement
ce sont des mesures visibles de
désescalade et d'une volonté sincère
d'engager le dialogue
personne ne veut résoudre ce conflit par
des moyens militaires
ce serait de la folie absolue mais s'il
n'est pas résolu par la force alors il
doit être résolu par la diplomatie et il
se peut que ce soit encore un peu
difficile épreuve que les tensions sont
loin d'être apaisées le ministère grec
de la défense a annoncé ce matin
exercices militaires conjoints avec
chypre à l'italie
et la france en méditerranée orientale
la zone disputée la turquie a également
mené des exercices militaires avec la
marine américaine selon le ministère
turc de la défense
le président turc eux met en garde la
grèce contre toute erreur menant à sa
ruine paris de son côté averti la
méditerranée orientale ne doit pas être
un terrain de jeu des ambitions de
certains et des dissensions en tout cas
entre athènes et ankara qui date d'un
demi siècle déjà et ces derniers mois
ont été décisifs pour la stabilité de la
région
[Musique]
on
oh
[Musique]
ok
bon
homo
[Musique]
non
oh
mais c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes
[Musique]
on
bertrand piccard vous vouliez prouvé que
l'on pouvait voyager au solaire et vous
avez fait le tour du monde
moi mon ambition c'est de montrer que
les technologies propres et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent faire des choses a
priori impossible sur leurs épaules
c'était vraiment le laboratoire volant
qui montrait que non seulement on
pouvait s'alimenter au solaire